[Musique]
en 2000 les français se sont prononcés
via un référendum en faveur du
quinquennat conséquence cinquante deux
mandats présidentiels au lieu de sept
autre conséquence l'élection
présidentielle a lieu maintenant à la
même période que les législatives le
débat politique proprement dit va se
nourrir maintenant d'une lecture
controversée du calendrier électoral les
législatives avant ou après la
présidentielle
le débat va durer des mois deux camps
s'affrontent ceux qui sont pour la
présidentielle en premier puis dans un
deuxième temps l'élection des députés
principalement le ps mais aussi quelques
centristes
si les législatives de 2002 auront lieu
avant l'élection présidentielle le choix
aura lieu l'élection législative et donc
la fonction présidentielle une nouvelle
fois aura perdu son sens et les autres
principalement à droite qui défendent un
calendrier avec en premier élections des
députés puis la présidentielle comme
initialement prévu ils accusent leurs
adversaires de manoeuvre politicienne le
président en première ligne mais j'ai
observé
que
les français
n'aimaient pas qu'on modifie les règles
du jeu voilà c'est dit derrière ce
changement de calendrier voulue par le
ps lionel jospin premier ministre aurait
un plan en tête tout ça ressemble à des
calculs des combinaisons tout ça n'est
pas bon pour la démocratie
lionel jospin est accusé de mener une
tactique politicienne en vue de la
présidentielle de 2002 le ps aurait trop
peur de perdre les législatives
mais si le calendrier est d'inverser
alors la route vers l'elysée serait tout
tracé on lionel jospin c'est peut-être
une manoeuvre mais c'est de la belle
manoeuvre
prenez garde de ne pas vous retrouver
dans le rôle de l'arroseur arrosé est
l'arroseur sera arrosé le calendrier a
bien été inversés mais ça ne lui a pas
servi lionel jospin ne sera même pas au
second tour en 2002 et ce calendrier
présidentielles puis législatives est
aujourd'hui encore critiquer même à
gauche au fond législatives sont la
répétition des présidentielles avec soin
une amplification c'est ce qu'on appelle
un effet de vague il menace mais je ne
le sens pas soit une correction c'est à
dire un rééquilibrage des pouvoirs une
cohabitation éventuelle mais je ne pense
pas encore une fois que ce soit la
logique du système et tout ça fait qu'on
a une sorte de monarque républicain pour
cinq ans sarko 1er qui possède tous les
pouvoirs avec une assemblée qui risque
fort d'être réduite à l'état d'un
parlement croupion hyper président
assemblée qui devient une chambre
d'enregistrement
une chose est sûre depuis cette réforme
du calendrier il n'y a plus eu de
cohabitation
[Musique]